[Musique]
pour les studios MELS c'était du cinéma
à Montréal l'année 2022 en étude a
oublié s'ils ont accueilli quelques
productions hollywoodiennes comme Scream
6 l'absence d'une méga-production a fait
mal 2022 chez MELS on a eu d'un côté
beaucoup de production locale
québécoises mais du côté des productions
étrangères surtout les productions
américaines vraiment un manque à gagner
si on regarde en versus une année
historique comme 21
[Musique]
être en veilleuse leur projet de 75
millions de dollars pour la construction
de nouveaux studios il y a un peu
d'attentisme dans le marché Montréal
demeure encore une destination
intéressante mais qui challenger
économiquement on espère que 20 23
viendra infirmer la tendance de 20 22 le
Québec fait face à une vie concurrence
internationale et d'autres villes
canadiennes on a accueilli une vingtaine
de tournages étrangers une dizaine de
séries une dizaine de films ce qui est
dans le bas de la fourchette de ce qu'on
accueille depuis les 10 dernières années
au Québec
car certaines villes sont prêtes à
dérouler le tapis rouge pour attirer les
productions étrangères comme le fait
l'Alberta pour le tournage de la série
de Last of Us les studios américains ou
les plateformes numériques nous le
disent il ne se gêne même plus pour dire
on aimerait bien au Québec mais votre
crédit d'impôt n'est pas compétitif même
sur le cloche du côté de la guilde des
réalisateurs qui explique que les
retombées des productions étrangères
bénéficient également la production
locale c'est des vases communicants
c'est important parce que ces emplois là
avec les productions étrangères ça fait
en sorte que demain tenir la main
d'oeuvre d'abord une stabilité d'emploi
de pouvoir offrir des emplois à l'année
longue et également de pouvoir avoir de
l'équipement des studios c'est ce qui
nous permet de maintenir tout le système
qui sont interrelientes les deux le
Québec a perdu de son élan sur la scène
internationale mais malgré les défis il
reste de l'espoir au cours des 10
dernières années Montréal a toujours été
dans le top 10 des villes où il fait bon
faire du cinéma et vivre du cinéma c'est
encore le cas cette année Montréal et je
pense la sixième ville au niveau du
magazine Movie Maker ce sont de bonnes
nouvelles
si 2023 comme un souci au ralenti les
artisans espèrent l'aide de Québec pour
changer le scénario et écrire une fin
heureuse hollywoodienne ici Nadia
Alexandre Chartier Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]